[SPEAKER_01]: All right, so you trance for four hours, and Leslie, do you want to just try and rest?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Take a rest and sleep for the amount of time that you need to?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And basically, the night wears on.
[SPEAKER_01]: You recover your spell slots.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's 1 p.m. in the morning.
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_01]: Leslie is actually sleeping, finally, next to you on the couch that you have in the room.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll wake him up and put some water for him to wake up a little bit or refresh himself on those little rags or whatever.
[SPEAKER_00]: We need to go check out the Alchemist shop.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_02]: What's the alchemist shop?
[SPEAKER_02]: It's the place that I'm afraid might have just burned to the ground.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh?
[SPEAKER_00]: Why'd you do that?
[SPEAKER_00]: It was the flames in the shop when I was dragging your master who had been injured.
[SPEAKER_00]: But why?
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because we were being attacked.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, I admit I was maybe a little overzealous with my fire spells.
[SPEAKER_00]: God!
[SPEAKER_00]: You don't mess around when you're dealing with assassins.
[SPEAKER_00]: Did you see the poison that he got hit with?
[SPEAKER_02]: He started bleeding black ooze out of his eyes.
[SPEAKER_02]: You could have just kicked them in the river or something.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't kick people into the river.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't kick anybody into the river.
[SPEAKER_02]: And that's why the building is probably on fire.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, that's what I'm saying.
[SPEAKER_00]: So let's go check it out.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's see if there's anything.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, I'm sure that by now it's the city's already involved.
[SPEAKER_00]: They were probably involved when we went to take a nap.
[SPEAKER_02]: What if we see a wanted poster with their face on it?
[SPEAKER_02]: They're not going to be that quick.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's gonna be like a knife that's like stamped to the post.
[SPEAKER_02]: It won't be that quick.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, the people that want us, they already probably know kind of, well, they may not know what we look like because I didn't get a good look at them either.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, it just depends.
[SPEAKER_00]: But, regardless, I toss them like a cloak, a hooded cloak.
[SPEAKER_00]: You gotta wear, keep your head covered.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because they know if they were spotting the alchemist, which that's where they came from, they didn't know I was there, they probably know that you work for the alchemist.
[SPEAKER_01]: Leslie puts on one of Jude's oversized cloaks.
[SPEAKER_01]: Jude is not that large, but this cloak is big on Leslie.
[SPEAKER_01]: The two of you walk down the stairwell and you see the effect of red-eye black rum.
[SPEAKER_01]: And this new keg of cider that has been brought here on the busy ends of Ferd's bar, they're still at it at 1 a.m. in the morning, drinking, having a plethora of new alcohol, supposedly from...
[SPEAKER_01]: The still?
[SPEAKER_01]: Owen Black.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_01]: The still hasn't been touched.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Somehow, Ferd got a supply.
[SPEAKER_01]: Of course, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: And they're taking full advantage of it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Luckily, this leaves them in a state that they don't pay much attention to you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because it's 1am and they're well-lickered.
[SPEAKER_01]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the two of you slip off into the night.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I want to stick to like kind of main streets.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's like 1 a.m., so I don't want to be going necessarily down any streets or, you know, named Murder Alley.
[SPEAKER_01]: So do you want to walk down this way to the main thoroughfare and walk through and come back that way, or do you want to try and take these back alleys?
[SPEAKER_01]: Back alley is shorter, but definitely.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, no, I'll take the main.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so the two of you walk down the well-traveled path to the Row of the Gods.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's well lit.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is the Row of the Gods, is that like, are there temples here or statues?
[SPEAKER_01]: Those are all rented temples where foreign gods come in and try and convert whoever they can.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's kind of like a...
[SPEAKER_01]: This is the row of the gods, and this is the row of the other people hawking their wares of that kind.
[SPEAKER_00]: You mean like, oh, I got my statue of the pharaoh.
[SPEAKER_01]: Red light district.
[SPEAKER_01]: The Vestal Virgins.
[SPEAKER_01]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's kind of an interesting little area right here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, I see you're well-satiated, brother.
[SPEAKER_00]: Come here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, I mean, there's definitely competition between these because, you know, money is something that is given.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, these are things, endeavors that Jude was never really...
[SPEAKER_01]: Cared about much.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the two of you just walked down.
[SPEAKER_01]: You notice as you go there are actually quite a few guards from the Palix District that are not from the foreign district that are on the street patrolling.
[SPEAKER_01]: So obviously the fire...
[SPEAKER_01]: You walked over some kind of an anthill.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I mean, it was a chemical fire, so... Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you walk down to here to make the turn to where the alchemist is, and there's actually a group of five guardsmen dressed in Upper City uniforms, staying there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so what's the shop look like from a distance?
[SPEAKER_00]: Is it still burning?
[SPEAKER_00]: Do we have to get past the guards?
[SPEAKER_00]: It's not.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: But you are going to have to get past the guards.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so they've got it cordoned off, so to speak.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sort of.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, I can't, or can I just walk by it and not be addressed by the guards so I can get a side view?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to start walking up that way?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I would like to, but only, I mean, like, if they're stopping everybody and they've got like a definite barricade, or can I just walk?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's 1 a.m. in the morning.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, if you want to walk that way, you can walk that way and see if they challenge you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Jude, we're just walking past.
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to make sure I've got a place that's on the other side of the alchemist shop in mind that I'm gonna go to.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Um, one of the guards comes up and goes, sorry, citizen, no one is allowed, allowed past this area.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Order Paul Ribeiro.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is Paul Ribeiro around?
[SPEAKER_00]: We just wanted to go to the other side, could I ask?
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, is he here, that's all.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is he a captain of the guard?
[SPEAKER_00]: The guy you're talking to?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: He looks like a sergeant.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: He goes, Paul Rivero is a prince of the city.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's not here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you cannot ask for permission.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_00]: I guess we'll go the other way.
[SPEAKER_00]: We turn and walk, please.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you start walking away.
[SPEAKER_00]: Um, shit.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do I know of a back alley way to get there?
[SPEAKER_01]: Dude, Warrens.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, they're probably gonna have that locked off, like, right before you come in, but... That's irritating, because I want inside that shop.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the Warrens are...
[SPEAKER_01]: Doing it check.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eight.
[SPEAKER_00]: Eight plus... Plus... Five.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, plus five.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thirteen.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, the Warrens are always dangerous.
[SPEAKER_01]: The Warrens are always dangerous, but if you want inside the shop...
[SPEAKER_00]: I could definitely get there through some Warren access.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, no.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, you definitely could.
[SPEAKER_01]: It would be an adventure, but the question is, why do that when you know Paul Ribeiro personally?
[SPEAKER_01]: And it would be nice to be marched down there by Paul Rivera and maybe ten guards to keep the local urchins and thieves off your back.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now the question is, do you want to do this without him?
[SPEAKER_00]: Without Paul?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, I mean, I'd like to find Paul.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's why I'd ask the guy if Paul was still around.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the guy was like, well, you can't talk to him, and no, he's not around.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Which means what?
[SPEAKER_00]: Nothing.
[SPEAKER_00]: He could still be around and the guy was just telling me to bug off.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I don't know how to find out if Paul's still there.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't want to get arrested by the guard and I don't want to have to run from the guard.
[SPEAKER_00]: That always sucks.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've done my share of that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Other than that, I'd have to traipse all the way back over to the palace, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Mm-hmm.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, like, up here?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ah, shit.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's no code word to be like, hey, I'm supposed to be training Paul.
[SPEAKER_00]: Like, I'm a stranger.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I mean, they know you there.
[SPEAKER_00]: At the palace?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, let's do that, because I go in.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right, let's go back up.
[SPEAKER_00]: I won't have to push my way past some guards.
[SPEAKER_00]: They've got it cordoned off, so whatever's not burnt to a crisp is probably gonna stay there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I'll go back up to the palace, drag him with me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so the two of you walk through the night.
[SPEAKER_01]: Reaching the northern gate at 1.30 a.m. in the morning.
[SPEAKER_01]: And what do you mean when you get there?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's locked or just there's guards?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's shut, but there are guys on station, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm looking for Paul Rivera.
[SPEAKER_00]: I know that there was a shop that was burned down there.
[SPEAKER_00]: I need to talk to him about it.
[SPEAKER_01]: The guard looks down at you and goes,
[SPEAKER_01]: Let him see me.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're the wizard.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Who is this?
[SPEAKER_00]: He's the alchemist's assistant.
[SPEAKER_00]: The shop that burnt down.
[SPEAKER_02]: Leslie, for sure.
[SPEAKER_00]: Stay here.